Mui: Good afternoon, everybody.
I know it's really tough
after lunch,
particularly for those
who haven't got lunch yet.
Uh, but we're going to spend
the next hour or so
talking about how to optimize
your Android app
with Google Analytics.
So here, uh, we--we--
the three of us are from
the Google Analytics team.
I'm Phil, this is Nick,
and that is Jim.
But really, Jim and Nick
are the experts in the group.
So as a show of hand,
how many of you
are not Google Analytics
users?
Oh, great. See why
I ask the opposite way--
it would be a very
different story.
So for those of you who
don't know Google Analytics,
that's a screen shot
from the current version
of Google Analytics.
It is essentially a tool
that helps you as a marketer,
developer, Web site owner,
to understand who are coming
to your Web site,
what they are doing,
and how you can optimize your
various marketing activities.
So in the last month or so,
we have released a slightly
new version of it.
So it looks something like that.
Who has seen
the new version already?
Raise your hand.
Great.
In this new version,
is a, uh, number internally,
that we, uh, called version 5.
So this is probably the most
significant version upgrade
that we have in the product
in the past five years,
since the beginning
of Google Analytics.
So many of you think of
Google Analytics
primarily in the vertical
of Web site analytics,
so let me reemphasize
and reestablish
your trust in Google Analytics
by showing you
a few of the customers
that use G.A. on a daily basis.
Who recognizes
the first icon?
[laughter]
Mui: Remember,
it is whitehouse.gov.
It is not whitehouse.com.
Uh, what about the second one?
What is that?
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Mui: Wow, my goodness.
This is a government employee
or somebody who is interested
to do spy work.
That is indeed the FBI,
along with a list
of Fortune 500 companies
and large companies
that you may recognize.
These are companies that use
Google Analytics exclusively.
Now the point I want
to make here with this slide
is many of you have heard about
various tracking issues
on the Web,
but if the U.S. government,
or if you prefer,
if Mr. Obama trusts
Google Analytics,
shouldn't you trust
Google Analytics also?
On the rich media side, this
is probably less well-know.
So here's a series of platforms
that have native
Google Analytics tracking
built into it.
Many of you develop
in AS3, ActionScript 3,
uh, or Adobe AIR,
or Microsoft Silverlight,
for the few of you
who still do that,
uh, AJAX applications
and so on.
If you would like to try
natively
your applications
in this platform,
there are various SDKs
you can download,
and do tracking
with your development.
On the mobile side--
so the reason that we are all
here is because of Android,
but it's also true
that we have a native SDK
with the iOS platform, for those
of you who develop in that area.
Perhaps these days,
in order for anyone to be hip,
you really have
to talk about Social.
And so here is a few
of the social measurement
companies,
plus tools that
will be useful to you
if you are interested
in this area.
So twitter.com, who is right
here in San Francisco,
is one of the largest
Google Analytics users.
Um, how many of you develop
Facebook apps?
Oh, really?
Okay, this must be
a Google conference.
So for those of you who would
like to develop Facebook apps,
it turns out that
there is an FBML tag
natively built into the, uh,
Facebook platform,
called Google Analytics.
And let me also,
as a show of hands,
anyone here play "FarmVille"?
Or anyone here who dare
to raise their hand
that they play "FarmVille"?
So it turns out that, you know,
that's one of the most popular
social casual games
on the Web.
Uh, FarmVille has been, uh,
optimizing it's, uh, experience,
with the help
of Google Analytics.
So that's--
that's pretty cool.
Now if you, uh, of course,
use any of the, like,
WordPress or iGoogle,
et cetera,
you would also realize that
for many of these platforms,
there are plug-ins, particularly
for Google Analytics.
So the point of this slide
is that many people associate
Google Analytics with
Web analytics tracking,
and this slide now, if you
have never seen this before,
can really tell
a different story.
What we are trying to do here
on the team
is try to build
a 360-degree tool
for you as a developer,
as a marketer,
to have that complete view
of your visitors
as they go through your
digital online experience.
So Google Analytics has evolved.
It has evolved
into an analytics platform--
or, we're still not there yet,
but we are definitely
working hard on it.
So focusing
on this presentation,
we are going to talk
about Android,
and we recently released
an update to Android,
and these are the two experts
who will tell you more about it,
but for those who--who care,
there are a few core
tracking capabilities
that you will be able
to get out of this native SDK.
Of course you can track
unique users
or page views and events,
and more recently,
you can also track
your e-commerce transactions,
if you do that
on your mobile phone,
um, or if you want to set
custom variables
or if you would like
to track market referrals
for the Android Marketplace.
So without exposing my, uh,
my ignorance of some of these,
I'm gonna pass to the experts,
who will tell you how
these things work. Nick.
Mihailovski: Thanks, Phil.
All right, guys, so today
we have a bunch of demos
that we're gonna present to you
on how you can leverage
our Google Analytics SDK
for Android.
Um, how--how many people here
have used Google Analytics
for Android?
A couple people.
Some people. Okay.
So for some of you,
this might be introductory,
but we're gonna take you through
the whole process
of best practices,
how to set it up,
as well as how to interpret
some of the reports
that you might not have used
in there previously.
So before we get into the demos,
I want to set a little stage
for people who are new
to the product, uh,
and talk about
how you get started.
Uh, it's really simple.
The first step is
we offer an SDK you can
download from our site.
It's a zip file which has a jar.
You link the jar
to your library,
and then you need to set
two permissions--
you set the internet
and the access network state
permissions,
and once you have that--boom,
you've done
all the configuration,
and you're ready
to start coding.
Now on the code side,
we also made it really easy.
The library provides a Google
Analytics tracker class,
and on the onCreate method
within your activity,
you grab an instance
of that class, uh,
which is returned
as a singleton,
and you call start,
and you pass it
your account ID
and the context.
An account ID is common
to what Google Analytics--
what you'd normally see
in a JavaScript interface.
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Mihailovski: All right.
Come talk to us afterwards,
and--it's fine.
Um, what I really want
to illustrate with this is
this is a very simple
snippet of code,
but magically,
there's a lot of stuff
that happens under the hood.
What we do is
if you're a first-time visitor
to an application,
we create a random ID,
and create a SQLite table
and store the ID in a table.
Now if you return
to the application,
we see if the table exists,
and we retrieve the ID,
and we can associate that unique
ID with the user.
Now this ID
is completely random.
It's not the device ID.
It does not tie to anything
personally identifiable.
What it allows us to do, though,
is track unique users
for the content
in your application.
So how many 7-day active users
do you have
using your app today
around the globe?
These are the questions
Google Analytics can answer.
So before we get into
the actual tracking, um,
it's also important
to understand
how data is sent
to Google Analytics.
So instead of when--
traditionally when you make
a tracking request,
data is sent directly
to analytics.
In RSDK, it's a little bit
different.
We actually store all the data
in a queue,
and then send all the data
as a batched request.
And this helps us save
battery life,
as well as allows us to track
users when they're offline.
So if there's a spotty
connection,
we can still track them,
and then finally when they
resume their connection,
we can send all the data
to analytics.
And to do that,
we can manually do it,
calling it a dispatch method,
or overload the start method,
uh, with the interval,
which is the number of seconds
to send all the data.
So now what we just talked about
was how to get the library
and get started,
we talked about how to
instantiate a tracker method,
and we just talked about
how to send data to analytics.
So let's get to tracking.
Now as application developers,
it's important to understand
how users interact with content.
So in Android, this means
tracking activities or views.
Now in the Web, we typically
measure viewing of content
as Web page views,
and this page view essentially
means that we're tracking
the number of loads
or the number of times
the screen has changed,
so in an application,
we can use the same concept
and track the number of times
the screen has changed as well
with page view tracking.
Now as a best practice,
we usually recommend
you use page view tracking
when there's a significant
amount of content
that changes on your screen,
and using something differently,
uh, when you track interactions
with the content.
And we'll show you that
a little bit later.
So with that,
let's get to the first demo
and talk about how
to track activities.
Cotugno: Thanks, Nick.
Uh, before I show code,
I want to tell you
that we're gonna use the notepad
sample application
that you can find
in the Android SDK,
and, uh, let me go through
that application
for those of you
not familiar with it.
Uh, here I have
the notepad application.
You can simply
add notes here.
See if I can type.
Oh, I can't type.
I don't know if many of you
have seen Nick at nite.
He's pretty funny, I hear,
so...
And then, uh,
you can edit notes.
Let's see if we can--
let's click on this.
And you can edit the title,
so let's put an exclamation
point on the title.
Oops. Well, that'll work.
And then you can delete, uh,
you can delete a note as well.
And that's the notepad
application in a nutshell.
So what I'm gonna do now
is add some tracking code
to the notepad application.
And here, uh, is my project.
Uh, and you can see, uh,
that we have
several activities
that make up
the notepad application.
I'll start with
the notes list activity,
which is the first one
that, uh, comes up
when you launch
the application.
And...
Oops.
Let's try this way.
And let's go to, uh,
I guess we'll start here.
I've declared an instance
of the tracker object
that I want to use
to do my tracking.
And then here,
in my onCreate method,
I've, uh, instantiated
instance of the tracker,
and I've started it up,
and then here on my onResume,
I'm gonna go ahead
and track the page view.
Let's see if I can highlight
that for you.
I'm using the application--
or the activity's class name
for this, uh,
so that's for my notes list.
I've also, since there are
several other activities here,
um, I've decided to create
a subclass
that they can all extend
called "tracked activity,"
and again, tracked activity
does, uh,
exactly the same thing.
onCreate, we start up a tracker,
and then onResume, uh,
we call track page view.
Now, uh, I would run
this application,
but you wouldn't
see a whole lot,
'cause all the tracking
happens behind the scenes.
Uh, fortunately for this latest
version of the SDK,
which we put out last week,
I added a little help
in terms of debug support.
So what I'm gonna do--
first off, I'm gonna shorten
my interval to one second,
so we see things happen quickly.
And then I'm gonna add,
uh,
a debug flag, turn that on.
What this will do is this will,
um, put some debug messages
in the log so that you can see
when the hits are generated
and what they look like.
And then there's another
feature we added, uh...
Calling it Dry Run,
and when you set that to true,
we won't actually send the hits
all the way to Google Analytics.
So you don't have to worry about
polluting your data space
while you're doing testing
and debugging.
So let me go ahead
and do the same thing
to the other class.
Add this code in there.
Mihailovski: Make sure
you save 'em, too.
Cotugno: You want me to save it?
Did you say you want me
to save this?
Okay, it's all saved.
Let's run it
and see what happens.
Well, actually,
before I run it,
let me show you a log--
you're probably all familiar
with logcat on the Android ADB.
Uh, we've, uh,
tagged all
our Google Analytics debugging
with, uh, the tag
Google Analytics tracker,
and you can see here,
I'm gonna run the logcat,
and I'm really only interested
in the tracking code,
and I'm gonna suppress
all the other
debug messages in the system,
so we're all set to go.
And we've run.
We go back,
and as you can see,
we've already gotten our per--
our first, uh, hit generated
as a page view,
uh, and you can see
that the activity,
uh, name--notes list is there.
If you recall,
that's the first view.
So I'm gonna go ahead--
I can't, uh,
you can't see real well
what I'm gonna do,
but I'm gonna go ahead
and add a note now.
And you can see now, uh,
we've got a page view track
for the note editor,
which is the activity class
that you use to enter notes.
And then I'm gonna go ahead
and edit the title.
I went back to the--
sorry, forgot about that.
Uh, going back and forth,
I'm gonna go ahead
and edit the title,
and you'll see the title,
um, come up here,
the title editor.
Oh. I must have pressed
a button there.
So you can see the page views
tracking is happening,
uh, pretty much as I navigate
through the application.
So at this point,
I want to turn it back to Nick,
so he can show you
the reports.
Mihailovski: Cool. Thanks, Jim.
So, uh,
so my slides aren't showing up
for some reason here,
but they should be.
So, um, when you log
back in to Google Analytics,
uh, in version 5,
you can go into
the content section,
the pages report,
and you can see the total
number of activities, uh,
and the number of page views
that you're tracking
for each of these activities.
And so the key part,
what Jim demonstrated was,
was that the class name, um,
by passing that to the track
view--page view method,
allows you to associate
the classes and activities
with the actual content
in the reports.
Now remember, um,
we talked a little bit
about having a unique user ID,
um, that's random,
associated with every time
a user interacts
with your content,
and what we can do
with the custom report
in Google Analytics,
is get a breakdown
of the total number
of unique users
who have actually looked
at one of your activities.
So to do that, we use what's
called a custom report,
and in the version 5 interface,
you see it in a new
custom reports tab.
Here we click
a new custom report.
We configure it
using the page dimensions
and the total visitors
in page views metrics.
Now what we do is,
once we click save,
we see a new report here
that shows us total visitors
as well as the total
number of page views.
Now this means
during the date range
of March 15th
all the way through April 14th,
this is the total number
of unique users
who have actually been
to these different activities,
which is kind of unique.
In this case, we see that
they're about the same,
so between the notes list
and the notes editor activities,
but significantly lower
in the title editor activity.
Now this means
people have never used
this part of the application
during this time,
and as a developer
you might question,
well, why aren't people--
why isn't this number similar
to these other activities?
Maybe they're not able to
explore and find this activity,
uh, maybe there's some
usability issues.
So what you're able to do here
is use the data
to understand where
there might be an issue,
and maybe a place where
you can start improving
the performance
of your activity, um,
and using the data
to help guide decisions
on how to, uh,
improve your applications.
So that's how we track
content interactions.
The next thing
we want to show you
is how you track, uh,
user interactions.
In this case, we use what's
called event tracking
in Google Analytics.
Uh, what we're interested
in tracking in our application
is the number of times people
delete and act--delete a note,
and we're also interested
to understand
from which activities
are notes deleted the most.
So, Jim, let's take a look
at a demo,
and see how to set that up.
Cotugno: Thanks, Nick.
Okay, so we're gonna take
our notepad application again,
and I'm gonna add some events
to track deleting the notes.
Now there's two places
you can delete a note--
you can delete a note
from the notes list--
the very--the main view,
and then you can delete
also from the note editor.
So here, um,
I have added code into, uh,
the notes list.
I've highlighted that--
whoops, wrong screen, sorry.
Let's try that again.
Okay, that's better.
So now I've added a track event
into the notes list
where, uh, where we process
the delete, um, function,
and we've added a category
of UI interaction,
the action is delete,
and the label--
we're using the activity
class name for the label here.
And, uh, value is not relevant,
so I set that to 0.
And here's
the note editor class,
and we do exactly
the same thing,
uh, UI interaction
is our category,
delete is our action,
and note editor, this time,
is the class.
Let's go ahead and run this.
And move over
to our logcat screen.
I'm gonna go ahead and add,
uh, a few notes here real quick.
So I've added a note "R,"
a note "Q,"
and I'm gonna add a note "S."
Guess I got the alphabet
a little wrong there.
I'm gonna go ahead
and delete my first note
from, um, the main screen.
I've deleted it,
and there you can see
the event track come through.
See if I can highlight
the relevant stuff.
There's the event category.
Uh, there's UI interaction,
a delete, and the notes list.
So let's go ahead and edit
the next note on our list.
And I'm gonna go ahead
and delete that.
And there's our second,
uh, event.
Let me...
And you can see that
this one indicates
that we used the note editor
to delete it.
And I have a third one here,
so let's go ahead and delete
that from the main screen.
And again,
you can see the event
come through and track.
That's really
all there is to it,
and Nick will show you
the reports again.
[clears throat]
Mihailovski: Thanks, Jim.
So once we've collected
the data,
we can now log again
back into the UI,
and start seeing
what's going on.
In this case, we look
at the content section,
now we go to the event section
and the top events report,
and here we see all the events
that we're starting to track.
And when we click this button,
boom, we get the number of times
a note was deleted overall.
And, boom, we can click on that,
and because we're sending
the class name,
which associates
with activity,
we can now differentiate
by activity
where people are deleting
this note the most.
Now we won't stop there.
What we really want to do
is not only look
at the total number of times
stuff was deleted,
but we also want to understand
the total number
of unique visitors,
or unique users,
who have actually used this
feature of the application.
And to do that, we can create
a custom report.
In this case,
we use the event
action dimension,
and event label dimensions,
and we also here are looking
at total visitors
and total events.
Now when we click save,
the report shows us
for every time
people deleted a note,
the breakout between
the notes list
and the notes editor,
as well as the total number
of unique visitors
in the date range
who have actually
used this feature.
Now in this example, we see
that the total number of times
people deleted a note
from the notes list section
was about four times greater
than the total number of people
who deleted a note from
the notes editor activity.
Now as an application developer,
I'm really curious in why are--
is nobody using
this feature that I spent
all this time developing
in my app?
Maybe people don't know
about the feature,
maybe the feature's hard to use.
It's again, using this data
that you collect
from Google Analytics
to help understand
where people are not really
leveraging your application
to your full potential.
It also might make sense,
you know,
if you're trying to understand
where to invest time
and resources,
you might either promote this
or try to get rid
of the feature at all
because people aren't using it.
So again, here's a great way
on how you can use data
to start optimizing
your applications.
So we just talked about
tracking views,
we talked about tracking
content interactions.
The third thing
we're gonna talk about
is tracking user preferences.
In this case,
what we want to understand is
how behaviors differ by
orientation of the device.
Are certain features used more
when it's in portrait mode
or landscape mode?
And what this example
will show you
is how to start using
Custom Variables
to track user preferences.
Now before we get
into the demo, uh,
how many people here know
what Custom Variables are?
Okay, so we're gonna--
we're gonna take a step back
and do a little conceptual
overview of how they apply.
So if you think
of an application,
you have a user who comes
to your application
and interacts with content.
He might return sometime,
view more pages.
He might even come back
and do a transaction.
In Google Analytics,
we call each of these
visitor, session,
and page levels.
Now a custom variable
allows you to describe
each of these levels,
so for example,
you might describe a visitor
who's made a purchase,
and compare them to visitors
who haven't made a purchase.
You might use a session
Custom Variable
to compare users
who have logged in
versus who haven't logged in.
And you might use
a page custom variable
to compare users who have gone
to a particular page
that belongs in a category--
for example, news versus sports.
Now in the Google Analytics,
uh, SDK for Android,
we make this really easy,
providing by--
providing the set custom bar
method.
Now this method accepts
four parameters.
At any given time you can send
up to five Custom Variables
to analytics,
so the first parameter is which
custom variable you want to set,
the second one's the name,
the third is the value,
and finally, the fourth
corresponds to the level.
In this case,
one is visitor,
two is session,
and three is page.
So now that you all know
how Custom Variables work,
Jim, let's see the demo of how
to track the orientation.
Cotugno: Okay, thanks, Nick.
Again we're taking our notepad
sample application,
and we're adding, um,
some Custom Variable
support here.
So here I'm showing you the code
in our tracked activity class,
and, uh,
you can see
at the beginning,
we're setting up our tracker,
uh, like before,
uh, and then we're determining
the orientation of the device,
and then finally you can see
we're set--
doing our setCustomVar call.
We're using slot 1.
Uh, the name for this custom
variable is screen orientation,
and the value is going to be
the orientation
that we determined above,
and we're gonna give it
a session scope, uh, which is 2.
I've done the same
for our notes list,
um, activity as well.
So let's go ahead
and run this.
You want to take this?
Mihailovski: Oh, yeah, sure.
Cotugno: Yeah,
you want to have...
Mihailovski: Okay,
is it running?
Cotugno: Not yet.
It will be in a second.
Okay, I've--
I've fired it off,
and you can see
we've already got
our first page view.
Mihailovski: So if I turn it
here, if I turn it back--
uh,
if I--
we add a note here...
and turn to editor...
And enter.
Cool.
So now we're tracking
all the orientation by, uh...
Yeah, cool.
Cotugno: You having fun
with that?
Mihailovski: Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
Cotugno: Okay, uh,
that's really all there is
for Custom Variables.
Why don't you show us what
the reports look like?
Mihailovski: So where does
Custom Variables show up
in all these requests?
Oh, we lost it.
Cotugno: It's back.
Mihailovski: Okay. Cool.
So now that we've collected all
this data as Custom Variables,
what's really powerful
about Custom Variables, uh,
is that we can create what's
called an Advanced Segment
and use--and segment
the number of users
who have used one preference
versus the other
across all of our reports.
So I'm gonna explain
what that means.
In Google Analytics, we have
what's called Advanced Segments,
and in the new interface,
you can see it under
the Advanced Segment tag.
When you click this button,
a little dialog pops up,
and you can see a bunch
of default segments,
as well as you have
the ability to create
a new Advanced Segment.
So in this case,
we'll create a new one,
and in the dialog,
what we say is,
we set the custom variable 1,
um, the value 1,
to exactly match every time
we're setting portrait.
Now what Jim was collecting
and sending to analytics
was the portrait string when
people were in portrait mode,
and landscape when people
were in landscape mode.
So here we create
a Custom Variable
to match all users who have
actually been in portrait mode.
We can similarly come back
into Analytics and create one
that's everybody
who was in landscape mode.
When we click slave,
we end up having
two custom segments.
So again,
what's great about this
is now these two
segments of users,
we can apply this to any
of the reports in Analytics
and compare the behavior
between each of the groups.
So let's go back to this, uh,
report that
we looked at earlier.
And in this case,
we saw that the notes list,
the total number of visitors
who viewed the notes list
and the notes editor activities
was effectively the same.
But now when we apply these
two new Advanced Segments,
we see a slightly
different story.
On the notes list side,
we see that people
significantly, uh,
used the portrait orientation
more than the landscape
orientation.
now that would make sense,
because in a list, there's--
you can have a lot more items
in a list
when it's in portrait mode,
versus in landscape mode,
when you have a lot
fewer items.
On the notes editor side, we see
something slightly different.
We see the usage
is about the same,
and if you think
of the flow of the app,
we see that when
you're in portrait mode
and you long press
to get into the edit,
the default orientation is--
is still portrait.
You actually have
to then go to landscape
to get the editor view.
But when we see the total number
of engagement or page views,
it's significantly higher
for those visitors
in landscape mode,
and that's probably because
users are preferring
to use landscape mode
while they're editing,
because the buttons
are a little bit wider.
So here's a great way on how
you can capture data from users
and their preferences,
apply 'em back into your reports
to see how they're
using your application
based on different preferences
they have in--that they've set.
Cool.
So the last demo that
we want to show you, um,
is--is a new feature
that we just launched last week,
which is E-commerce Tracking
in our SDK.
So increasingly, uh,
applications are enabling people
to buy virtual goods, and to
conduct e-commerce transactions
directly in the app,
so with this new update,
we allow you to track
transactions and items
directly in Google Analytics.
So before we go into the demo,
I kind of want to talk
a little bit about, uh,
the different components
and how they all work together.
So if you think
of a shopping basket,
you have one transaction
and a bunch of items.
In Google Analytics, each
of these are different objects,
so you have one
transaction object,
and a bunch of different
item objects
that you can create,
which are data,
and they're all tied together
using an order ID.
So once you have those objects,
you add 'em to the tracker,
calling the addTransaction
and additem methods,
and what this happens is--
it effectively fills
your shopping basket
in an e-commerce bucket--
buffer.
And once the buffer--once you
have all your items defined,
you call track transactions,
and this sends it
to the dispatcher,
which then queues it up
to send it to Google Analytics.
So now that we see how
all the pieces work together,
Jim, let's see how it works.
Cotugno: Okay, thanks.
So we have, um,
if you've looked at the samples
for in-app billing,
um, there's the one called
"Dungeon,"
and I've taken that and I've
made some modifications,
uh, to make it
a little bit more interesting
and to add some tracking
for e-commerce.
So here's the key method.
This is a callback
on purchase date change,
and this gets called
when the transaction
that you've requested has been,
um, confirmed by the system,
and what I've done then
is added code to, uh,
log the transaction
in Google Analytics, uh,
at this point in time.
So if you look
at the highlighted code
near the bottom, uh,
you can see that, uh,
if the purchase
has--has gone through,
the purchase state
is--is "purchased."
We're gonna add a transaction
to the tracker,
and, uh, we pass in
an order ID,
which is passed in to us
in this callback method,
and then, uh, for price,
uh, all items in this demo
application are 99 cents,
and so we just put
a 99 cent price in there.
And then we add an item, uh,
we use the order ID
that's passed in
so we can tie the transaction
back to the item,
and then we add in the item ID,
uh, which is passed in
as part of this callback.
And again, every item
is 99 cents,
and for this application, uh,
every transaction
is one item purchased.
Uh, so let's go ahead
and run this.
Make sure--
I want to make sure
that our log--logging is on.
It is.
Let's go ahead and run this.
And what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna flip over to the device
so you can see, uh,
this application
a little bit.
So, uh, here's the application.
It's got one light item,
so you can select, uh,
a blue sword
or a red sword
or a potion for purchase.
And when you do that, uh,
let's try it.
You'll get this
confirmation screen.
We'll go ahead and purchase,
and the purchase
has come through.
So let's flip over
to our logcat screen,
and as you can see,
we have two hits
have been generated.
One--the first one--
Let me highlight it here--
is the transaction hit.
You can see the order ID.
It starts it at 1-3,
and 1 line and comes across,
and then you have
our item hit coming next.
You can see, uh,
it's got the same order ID.
Should be able
to see that there,
and the blue sword
is what was purchased.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and purchase a few potions here,
'cause I need lots of help.
Mihailovski: Keep dying
in the game?
Cotugno: Oh, wait.
I purchased another blue sword.
Mihailovski: Hmm,
you like the blue swords, huh?
Cotugno: Yeah,
I got two of those now.
All right, so let's try--
let's try a potion now.
And there it is.
You should be able to see
the potion.
And I need lots
of healing potion,
so let me buy
a few more here.
There it is.
And there it is.
And that, uh, that's
all there is to it really.
So, Nick, why don't you show us
what the reports
would look like.
Mihailovski: Cool.
So once you've collected
the data,
in the new version 5 interface,
you simply go
to the conversion section,
uh, the e-commerce
and product performance,
and then at the bottom we'll
show you the total quantity,
unique purchases,
revenue associated
with each of the products.
So again in this case,
you know,
the blue sword was bought
multiple times,
uh, compared to the red sword.
If that's the case with
products, you might consider--
you know, there's a preference
to blue,
maybe we need more blue to--
blue items in the store.
Um, having the data there
allows you to start
making these questions
and starting to test some ideas.
So with that, um,
that's the end
of our presentation.
Um, it's--like,
the presentation went
really short,
because it's that easy for us
to--for people to do,
so we highly recommend
you, um,
go to our documentation,
download the SDK,
and then all the code
that we showed today
is available
at Analytics API samples.
Um, if you liked
the presentation,
tweet it using the hash tag
Android,
and if you have any feedback,
let us know.
Let us know if we did good
or bad,
uh, and we'll--we'll
open it up to Q&A.
Cotugno: Thank you.
[cheers and applause]
Mihailovski: Yeah?
woman: Um, in the new SDK, we're
working with fragments a lot.
Do you have any best practices
for working with fragments
instead of the activities?
Cotugno: Uh, not at the top
of my head, no.
woman: Okay.
Cotugno: So sorry.
woman: No problem.
man: Hi, uh, I have
a client server application,
and I also use Google Analytics
on the server side.
Mihailovski: Mm-hmm.
man: Do you have any advice
on how I can correlate activity
between user's activities
on the client and on the server.
Mihailovski: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So, um, right now there's
no good solution for that,
the key being that you need
a primary key
between both environments.
Um, right now there's no way
to override a visitor ID,
which would be the primary key.
Um, so not at this time.
man: Okay, thanks.
man: Hey, um,
is there a way to log
all of the Google Analytics
data, and then send it later
at, like, a user
connects to Wi-Fi,
in one big batch request
or something?
Cotugno: Yeah, uh,
there's two modes of dispatch.
What happens is when you
actually log the hit
in your code, it gets--
it gets stored locally,
and then it will get dispatched
either through
the automatic dispatch
mechanism, which is periodic,
or you can do it manually
yourself.
Um,
so if you wanted to wait until
you got a Wi-Fi connection,
for example, you would, uh,
write a receiver
that would say--
that would call dispatch
whenever a Wi-Fi connection
was available.
That would be the way
to do that.
man: Okay, thanks.
Mihailovski: Cool. Yeah.
man: Uh, is there now,
or are there plans to have
functionality for doing this
sort of tracking with the NDK?
Cotugno: I'm sorry?
man: With the native
developing kit? The NDK.
Cotugno: Development--
oh, for Android?
man: Yeah.
Cotugno: I don't think
we have any plans right now...
man: Okay.
Cotugno: we can talk about.
man: All right, thanks.
man: Um, any plans to open
source the client code?
Mihailovski: Yeah,
that's a good question.
So currently we don't
have an open protocol
for collecting stuff.
We do have a bunch of the client
libraries, like Phil mentioned.
Um, it's something
that we'd like to do,
but there's a lot of stuff
to get to there.
man: Because--
Mihailovski: So currently--yeah.
man: The main reason why my app
crashes right now is because
I think it uses
the scroll lighting in the...
Mihailovski: Mm-hmm,
as the table--
as the persistence, yeah.
man: Yeah, and also,
when it goes off, it--
there's a lot of memory
exception
or something like that,
because it--
I send lots of events...
Mihailovski: Mm-hmm.
man: Um, and I had to wrap
all this code around the--
the analytics
to--to make it synchronous,
because, uh,
since it uses
a scroll light,
every time I insert something,
there is sometimes on the SD
card, or the phone is slow,
the internal memory is slow,
then it takes, like,
200 milliseconds to insert.
Cotugno: Oh, yeah.
man: So, um, I can't really
trigger events
on, uh,
onCreate and all this stuff,
otherwise it will slow down
a lot.
Cotugno: Okay.
Mihailovski: So currently, yeah,
it's not open source.
The code wasn't really designed
to be modular in open source,
but maybe--maybe we could
chat afterwards to--
Cotugno: Yeah, I'm gonna
go upstairs to the Android,
uh, office hours...
man: Cool.
Cotugno: So if you want to talk
more there, that'd be great.
man: Hi there, question's
around white space--
so I want to track
user comments,
but the white space really
killed me for a couple hours.
Um, I guess really,
you guys log it as a warning,
but maybe it should be
an exception, or--
and my second question is,
do you expect all white space
to give me headaches,
uh, or just the space--
'cause we're really putting it
into page view,
and page view should
not have any spaces.
Mihailovski: Yeah,
so the page view is supposed--
man: Thanks.
Mihailovski: Yeah,
it's a great piece of feedback.
Um, if you use event tracking,
it supports white space.
Page views don't.
Yep?
man: Hi, we do our own
tracking right now,
and, um, will often alter
our server response
based on user,
um, behavior.
Is there any opportunity
to query for, um,
query your system
for information about a user?
I mean, our information.
Mihailovski: Sorry,
explain it?
man: Yeah, so we'll have
a user,
if a user's ever
bought something,
we'll actually send different
messages to them
than a user that hasn't...
Mihailovski: Mm-hmm.
man: So on our server side,
we need to know whether,
you know, a user falls
in a certain category.
Can we query from our server,
query Google Analytics
for information that's stored
on our behalf?
Cotugno: You can't get
personally identifiable
information out of the SDK
at all, so...
Mihailovski: Yeah, so from--
maybe it's something different.
So what we're talking about here
is collecting data,
so if there's some data
in your system
that you want to send into G.A.,
uh, and associate with all
the user behavior,
you can do it through
the collection side.
If you wanted to query for data
that's already been processed
and then pull it back
into your own system
to close the loop,
we have an export API,
which you can then use.
So in that case, you usually
have some sort of common ID,
like a transaction ID,
or a custom variable
you can pass an ID in,
and then you can
query our export API
against that ID
and get all the usage data,
and then put that
into your system,
and then further act on it.
man: Okay, thanks.
Mihailovski: Yeah.
man: Yeah, um,
you mentioned that, uh,
the user ID is stored
in SQLite--
uh, that's, uh,
in the application's context,
so if somebody does
a clear data,
it's gonna wipe that out
and generate a new one
the next time they log in?
Cotugno: That's correct.
man: Okay.
Cotugno: And every time
the app is--
if you uninstall the app,
it'll also get wiped out.
So it will retain it, though,
if you upgrade the app
without uninstalling.
man: Right, and then we, uh,
run our applications across
multiple different kinds
of devices--
Android, RIM, et cetera.
Is there any way that
we would be able to track,
uh, the same kinds of events
in the other, uh,
platforms that
we are working with?
Mihailovski: That's
a good question.
So we have support for Android
natively, and iOS.
Um, we just released the debug,
Dry Run and e-commerce
in Android,
so we're working on that,
to get that in iOS as well.
Um, for the other devices,
we don't have any native
application tracking.
What we have is mobile snippet,
uh, server side stuff,
so if you have mobile,
like, kind of Web site,
Web experiences, you can
track in those devices,
even though they
don't generally store--
you know, they don't have
a great persistence mechanism.
man: No, these are entirely
apps, so...
Mihailovski: Yeah, okay.
So currently--
currently, we don't have it.
Yeah?
man: My question is on,
you know,
so a lot--each view you...
[speaking indistinctly]
you know,
is there any way--are you guys
using any HTTP pipelining
so that same connection
can be used on all the data?
You know, all--every time
you send data,
you're making a new connections
for the servers?
Mihailovski: Yeah, so what--
what we--
the way that we implemented here
is we used HTTP 1.1,
so we actually do pipelining
over that,
so the reason why
we're batching this stuff
is so we can pipeline it,
and the reason was because
when we first built it,
we didn't do it, and then
all the battery went away.
man: Okay.
Mihailovski: So then
we put it together,
and now it doesn't take up
all the battery.
So that's a great question.
man: Another question is, is
there a way I can, uh, make it--
you know, when I know the last
activity out of my, you know,
application is exited
at the time,
can I push all the data
to the server, you know,
stack them at the last time?
Mihailovski: Sure.
man: I don't want any
data transaction in between
my application.
Cotugno: Right, and that's
the manual dispatch
I talked about before.
You could actually call--
the method's called dispatch
in the tracker,
and if you start the tracker
and you pass it, uh,
minus 1, I think,
it will not do
any automatic dispatching.
It will wait for you
to tell it to dispatch.
man: Okay, so I can call it
at the--
the time user exits.
Cotugno: Right.
There's one caveat there.
It will only dispatch
up to 30, uh, hits at a time,
uh, so you might loop through
and call it several times,
or if you keep track of how many
hits you've generated,
you'll know if you have to,
uh, call it more than once
to make sure it goes through.
man: Okay, thank you.
Cotugno: Sure.
man: Um, when doing
the automatic updates,
do you synchronize
with the set in exact
timer type things
so that you'll piggyback
on when, uh,
Google push and the other things
are waking the device up,
or is there a value
you can pass in
for aligning with that?
Cotugno: No, right now
we just dispatch, uh,
as frequently as the time
interval that you requested,
so if you request ten seconds,
we're gonna dispatch
more or less every ten seconds,
maybe a little longer.
man: Okay.
man: On one of your
initial slides,
I think you had a bullet about
market referrals being something
that's integrated
into Google Analytics.
Mihailovski: Yeah.
man: Is there a way to get
information about
how your app is, uh, you know,
the detail page within Market,
and then the downloaders--
Mihailovski: Fantastic feature.
We did not demo it today,
so, um, so for the people
who are staying late,
we'll tell you a new feature
that's--
it's been in there for a while.
So what happens is,
let's say you have an ad
that you're trying to get people
to download your application
through the Android Market.
Um, you can add to the link that
points to the Android Market,
our referral parameters.
With the Android Market,
once somebody downloads the app,
um, it'll broadcast an intent
with all the parameters,
which there's a couple--
there's one more configuration
we didn't talk about,
but it's all under Docs--
it'll read that,
and then associate that campaign
with the download as well.
So you can definitely use that,
and it's--
it's actually
really helpful.
man: So a follow-up
question on that,
is there any way to get if a
user as coming through a search
in Market, as opposed to
an advertising-based intent?
Mihailovski: Currently--
man: Um, is there a way
to get search parameters?
Mihailovski: Currently, no.
You specifically
have to tag them.
man: Um, there--Google Analytics
has lots of various,
uh, pieces of data,
like average time on page,
um, things like that--
uh, are those useful
at all in this context?
They seem random for my app.
And is there any plan to add
the ability to say
when someone left
an activity?
Mihailovski: Uh, yeah,
that's a good question.
So the averages might
be a little bit misleading,
because it's kind of
a calculated metric.
Uh, total time is probably
a better metric to look at,
and I think it's available
through the custom reporting,
but just not the standard--
standard reports.
So we'll take a look at that.
So in many of the cases,
the averages, um,
might be a little bit off,
but the totals should add up,
right, the total time
would be how many people,
you know,
that will always add up.
man: Okay, thanks.
Mihailovski: Sure. Cool.
All right, cool.
If you have more questions,
come to office hours.
Cotugno: Thanks a lot, guys.
[applause]